In this part of our optimization tools,
I'd like to talk about scalability settings
as they allow you to adjust the rendering
demands of any scene quickly and easily inside
of the editor.
We can also use scalability commands
to adjust how our project is going
to look in a settings menu in the final product
once it's been cooked and ready for a user to utilize.
Now, what scalability does is, again,
it adjusts how things are going to be rendered.
So in the example in front of us, we
can see the various default scalability settings
taken right from the editor.
And if we were to click on, say, Near or Low or Medium,
we are going to reduce the settings that
are used or the rendering demands
for that particular category.
For example, if we adjust our view distance to Near,
we are going to reduce the amount of objects
that are going to be rendered by pulling the culling
or telling the renderer to stop rendering objects
past a certain distance closer to the camera.
Now, the exact opposite of this is true.
If we were to go from, say, Near to Epic or even
Cinematic, we would be increasing that distance
or increasing that rendering parameter.
Now, this does have quite a significant effect
on the overall look of your scene.
Here we have an example taken from the Electric Dreams demo
that shows Low, Medium, High, Epic, and Cinematic all taken
from the same spot.
And we can really see the difference
between Low and Cinematic.
There is just no shadows in Low.
There is no subsurface scattering.
It's a very low-end looking scene.
And then as we start to get to Medium, High, Epic,
and Cinematic, we're really starting to turn up the details
and increase the overall quality of the scene.
Now, there's a tool that we can use
to help us further define what is set inside
of these settings.
And we do that using something called the Device Profiles
tool.
Now, the Device Profiles tool allows
us to specify how our project should look when run on a wide
range of different devices.
Now, to utilize this, we're going to open it up inside
of our Unreal Editor session as a separate tool.
And then all we need to do to activate each profile
is click on the three little ellipses
next to the name of the profile we wish to activate.
So let's pop over to the editor
and look at how we do this.
So we're going to come up here to our tools.
And then under Platforms, we're
going to have our Device Profiles.
So right here is our Device Profiles.
And again, if we want to grab our Windows Editor,
I'm just going to hit these three little ellipses right
here.
And this is going to bring up the profiles for this.
So you can see here, we have a bunch of different things
that we can do.
Underneath Rendering, we can add rendering commands
like maybe allow HDR or allow static lighting.
And once we put one of those in there,
I'm just going to expand this.
You can see here, we can allow static lighting.
And if we hover over this, it actually
is also going to give us a little description of what
this command does and the inputs it requires.
We can also do this for our scalability group.
You can see here, we have anti-aliasing.
We have quality number of levels for our effects,
our foliage, a whole bunch of other options.
And again, I can do this if I just close that down here.
I can do this for everything.
So here is something for iOS.
If I scroll down this list further,
you're going to see there's a bunch of iPhones in here,
iPads, Mac TV.
There's all types of Linux stuff.
There's Android, all types of different things inside of here
that we can set these device profiles to.
And again, this allows us to adjust
how our project is going to look,
not only inside of the editor, but also
on the wide range of devices it could be published for.